and hello again from fox news in
washington we saw major action by the
fda and cdc this week to approve booster
shots for millions of more americans and
also new guidance on mix and match
getting the initial dose of one vaccine
and then a booster shot of another
plus public health agencies are getting
closer to approving covet vaccines for
children under 12. and the controversy
continues over public agencies and
private companies imposing vaccine
mandates on their employees all this as
americans try to prepare for the holiday
season as you can see there's plenty to
discuss with the director of the centers
for disease control dr rochelle wolinski
doctor welcome back to fox news sunday
thanks for having me good morning chris
so as we said the cdc this week approved
the moderna and j and j
vaccines for for millions of more
americans as well as approving
mix and match you say that it's it's a
personal option as to the individual
whether they want to get the initial
dose of one vaccine and then the booster
of another vaccine but isn't the data
clear that if you got the j and j
booster first that you get much more
protection by getting a booster from
either pfizer or moderna
so um this is an important next step in
our booster plan across this country
because right now we have a booster plan
for every one of the vaccines that we
are using as you noted the moderna
vaccine will
also be eligible for boosting the same
way the pfizer is as well as a booster
plan for j and j two months after your
initial dose we also approved a plan so
that we can move forward with mix and
match but specifically to your question
you know we saw data the fda and the cdc
saw important data from the nih on the
mix and match approach and how when you
boost a j j vaccine with a pfizer or
modern vaccine you get a really good
antibody response we also saw clinical
data from j and j themselves that when
you boost the j and j with a j and j
vaccine that you actually get really
good effectiveness there as well so that
is really why we left it
to the the people because quite honestly
most people did really well with their
initial vaccine series the vast majority
of people did really well we have 410
million people who've been vaccinated or
410 million vaccines that have been
given and so people may very well want
to pick the one that they got before
however if you want something else we
left that option up to you just briefly
though the according to the data if you
get the jnj booster after the jnj
initial dose it boosted your antibodies
fourfold if you got the moderna booster
after jnj it boosted your antibodies 76
fold i mean
if you were talking to your friend or a
relative
it seems like it's a no-brainer
well so we'd have different kinds of
data that's data in the lab and antibody
response but we saw data in people and
clinical effectiveness that demonstrated
a really good response to jnj as well so
i think i would really leave it up to
the clinical situation if i was talking
to a specific person people who did well
with j j may want it again but they may
very well want an mrna and that would be
absolutely fine too
could you at some point
change the definition of what it means
to be fully vaccinated to the initial
dose plus the booster that that's going
to be what it means
the definition of fully vaccinated is
pfizer or medora after you've received
two doses you are considered fully
vaccinated and after j j a single dose
you are considered fully vaccinated i
want to be very clear about that
so the boosters are not going to change
that definition at least at this point
we don't have a plan to change that
definition right now the fda advisory
panel will vote this week on whether
to approve emergency use of the pfizer
vaccine for 28 million children ages
5 to 11 and the cdc panel is supposed to
meet the week after next the first week
of november assuming everything goes
well how soon could you be sitting there
as a cdc director saying
kids 5 to 11 it's safe to get a vaccine
we know how many parents are interested
in getting their children between five
and 11 vaccinated and we intend to act
as quickly as we can so importantly as
you note the fda will meet this week
soon thereafter after they are able to
review all the science and conduct the
regulatory action the cdc will meet and
all if all of that goes smoothly after
reviewing all that science and doing the
proper scientific due diligence we will
act quickly what i can also say is in
the meantime there's important
logistical and operational plans that
are underway so that that vaccine will
be out in the field as soon as we take
action
look it's one thing to say whether
you're going to get a vaccine it's
another thing to say whether you're
going to let your five-year-old get a
vaccine and in a poll
that just came out only a third of
parents said that they would be willing
to let their children even if it's
approved by the fda and cdc let small
children get the vaccine quote right
away how tough do you think it is going
to be to convince parents
once you go through all of these
approvals that it's safe to get a 5 to
11 year old give them a vaccine and
should at that point should schools
mandate that kids of this age get the
vaccine as they do lots of other
vaccines
right so we have um i'm really excited
and enthusiastic about reviewing this
science and i'm really hopeful that in
that proper review we will get to a
place where we have a vaccine for five
to 11 year olds when and if we do we
have a lot of parents as you noted a
third who are ready to get their
children vaccinated right away and we
know we have a lot of work ahead of us
just as we did with the initial vaccine
these numbers are exactly the same as
they were early late december last year
when the initial vaccine rolled out and
yet today we have over nearly 80 percent
of people who receive their first dose
so we have to do all of that hard work
again education communication so that we
can get parents comfortable with getting
their children vaccinated where so many
parents are already how would you feel
about schools mandating those vaccines
once they're fully approved
you know right now we are at
authorization we're having discussions
about authorization so i think we need
to
you know get children vaccinated through
this authorization and you know get to
approval before we can make a judgment
there let's talk about mandates for
adults the president biden was asked
about the quite controversial mandates
for essential workers at his town hall
this week take a look at his answer
should police officers emergency
responders be mandated to get vaccines
and if not should they be
stay at home or let go yes and yes
now mandates by government by private
companies have
of essential workers have generally work
you see a big boost in vaccinations even
though there may be some grousing but as
you know there are cases where police
officers or health workers or pilots are
walking off the job rather than get the
vaccine are you still
full speed ahead on
mandates for essential workers to get
vaccinated
we have seen that these mandates are
getting more and more people vaccinated
here's what we know the most disruptive
thing that you can do to a workforce is
to have a covet outbreak in that
workforce that will most definitely not
only send people home but it will send
people to the hospital and some may pass
what we know from the police workforce
is that there have been more deaths from
the coronavirus over the last year and a
half than all other causes of death for
that workforce combined so we believe it
is very important to get these people
vaccinated there is a plan
should these people not want to be
vaccinated towards education and
counseling to get people the information
they need so that they are feeling
comfortable in getting vaccinated but
what about the argument that we're
talking about public health here and if
you've got and we've seen some real
resistance for instance in the chicago
police department in the interest of
public health on vaccinations if you
have a large part of a police force
leaving
in terms of public health having aren't
you further behind the ball rather than
having made gains
you know the the way you can down a
police force is by having a covet
outbreak in that police force so what
we're working to do is mitigate that
from happening
finally let's talk about where we are on
covet and let me put some of the the
latest stats up cases are down more than
50 percent in the last month but we're
still seeing an average of more than 73
000 new cases a day
and more than 1500 deaths a day which is
still pretty bad so
first of all
where are we on the delta wave
so i think the numbers actually speak
from themselves you're absolutely right
cases are down they're down more than 50
percent from where they were in
september but we can't get complacent
yet as we said 75 000 cases a day
1500 deaths a day the good news compared
to where we were a year ago is that we
have vaccines that work and that we have
a lot of science that demonstrates how
we can protect ourselves and how we can
get cases down further we know it's
critically important to get people
vaccinated all those 64 million people
who have not yet been vaccinated and
then with
scientific review if we have a vaccine
for our five to eleven-year-olds working
to get them vaccinated and in the
meantime practicing all the proper
mitigation strategies so that we can get
those case numbers and death numbers
down so do you believe that we are in
the downturn of the of the delta wave
that we that the spike is over and it's
heading out
you know we i'm really encouraged to
watch the numbers go down the last
several days they've been hanging out at
around 75 000 and so we still have some
hard work ahead of us in order to bring
those numbers down to where they were in
may and june and what about and you hear
people talk about this what about the
chances of another fifth wave of the
virus as the weather begins to get
colder and people start spending more
time indoors
well i'm encouraged by numbers coming
down right now but i have learned that
we can't be complacent and that we need
to be humble and that the virus tends to
find places that are under vaccinated so
as our case numbers come down we need to
continue to do the hard work of getting
more and more people vaccinated to
prevent exactly what you describe
you know there's a lot of good sports on
tv these days and if you watch sports
whether it's football games and stadiums
or playoffs and baseball you've got some
pictures up on the screen right now
doctor you see
hundreds thousands tens of thousands of
people all packed together not a mask in
sight i understand it's outdoors
but
what does it tell you that there have
not been spikes in most of these
communities when you have people crowded
into football or baseball stadiums
we would still encourage people who are
unvaccinated to wear a mask in those
situations but given that these games
are outdoors that tends to be a much
safer environment
finally
the holidays first of all halloween what
would you say that kids
can do and can't do
i would say put on those costumes stay
outside and enjoy your trick-or-treating
whether
whether people are vaccinated or not as
long as you're outside you're you're
safe
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't gather in
large settings outside and do screaming
like you're seeing in those in those
football games if you're unvaccinated
those kids that aren't vaccinated but if
you're spread out doing your
trick-or-treating that should be very
safe for your children and what about
thanksgiving and christmas
you know it's critically important that
we gather that we be together with our
family and friends during these holidays
and we have the prevention strategies
that we know work to be safe for those
holidays so what i would say is get
yourself vaccinated before you gather it
will absolutely be safer if you're
vaccinated any activity that is outdoors
is safer than it is if it's indoors and
if you're gathering multiple households
make sure as many people are vaccinated
as possible
so you can protect the people who are
vulnerable who might not yet be
vaccinated our young children are
elderly and then do all those prevention
strategies that we know work
before you arrive and as you arrive to
make sure that everybody can be safe for
the holidays and make sure that you're
well as you gather
wolenski thank you thanks for your time
this sunday a lot of good advice there
always good to talk with you
likewise thanks so much chris hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now